a California teenager is under arrest
for trying to steal a small plane at an
airport surveillance video shows the
plane maneuvering erratically on the
ground at Fresno Yosemite International
Airport before crashing no one was hurt
Mulla leg is here with how this happened
mola how did a teenage girl pass
security
yeah great question Anthony you know
airport security says that the teens
somehow climbed what was thought to be a
secure perimeter fence as she was able
to get into the plane start one of its
engines and then apparently tried to fly
it right off the runway airport
surveillance video captures the moment
two plane apparently tried to take off
it's sped erratically crashing into a
fence before colliding into a building
fresno officers arrive first and
contacted a female who was seated inside
the aircraft in the pilot seat wearing
the pilots headset but instead of a
pilot it was a 17 year old girl who
scaled a barbed wire fence before
attempting to steal the King Air 200
propeller-driven aircraft Wednesday
morning the aircraft never became
airborne and there was no fire the
aircraft did sustain some substantial
damage however police described the team
is disoriented and uncooperative when
they boarded the plane to arrest her
the teens father can be heard shouting
and telling the teen not to resist as
officers put her in handcuffs the
airport told CBS News no passengers or
commercial airlines were ever at risk in
the incident which raises fresh concerns
about the security of empty parked
planes airlines q400 what the [ __ ] is he
doing over here in August 2000 18 an
airline employee died after stealing an
empty Horizon Air turboprop plane from a
Seattle Airport and intentionally
crashing it onto a remote island nearby
crazy stuff yeah the team was booked at
a juvenile detention center nearby and
authorities say that there doesn't
appear to be any connection to any sort
of domestic - everybody ends up being
okay you do wonder how she got in yeah
clearly very troubled yes that's what I
said she would even try to do that yeah
a lot of question I hope she gets the
help she made well thank you very much